that statistic that that trump has made
people more optimistic than they were
four years ago about where they are in
the country
that is that is an astonishingly
positive statistic
for an incumbent president but trump is
trailing in the polls
and the media have a stake obviously
they hate trump the coverage of trump
for the last
four years since his election that
coverage
has been overwhelmingly bad i mean 90
percent of the coverage has been
negative on trump
despite all the accomplishments despite
the fact that the economy was booming
every single thing that trump has done
wrong has been magnified and every
single thing that he has done right has
been minimized
to the point where peace breaks out in
the middle east and suddenly that is now
being printed on page a18 of the new
york times
whereas if if barack obama had farted
anywhere in the general region it would
have been a1 news
anytime barack obama said a thing that
the media loved which was every single
day
a1 news whenever trump says something
that they don't like that is a1 news but
when he does something that is wonderful
that is page a18
and right now the media are so open in
their bias
it's one of the reasons why the left
cannot be allowed to win this election
because the media apparatus
have basically mobilized full score
behind the hard radical left position
while pretending to be objective at the
same time
it's insulting to the american people
it's ridiculous they've given up
any pretense that they once had of
objectivity but then they gaslight you
by claiming they continue to be
objective journalists they simply
are not and the best case in point of
this is the fact that joe biden
the democratic presidential candidate
the likely next president by the polls
and his running mate kamal harris
refused to answer a very simple but
quite important question
are you going to pack the supreme court
are you going to add seats to the
supreme court of the united states
remember
that was a policy so radical that fdr in
1937 when he tried to do this
was rebuked by members of his own party
the republicans did not control congress
at that time
democrats overwhelmingly controlled
congress and democrats in congress were
like
i think we're gonna like hit pause on
this one democrats now however are so
angry at the prospect of amy coney
barrett replacing
ruth bader ginsburg on the supreme court
because they believe the supreme court
should just be a tool of policy-making
on behalf of the left
rather than a a counter-majoritarian
institution
designed to prevent excesses that
overrun your rights which is the
original design
of the supreme court they believe the
supreme court should just be another
tool in their arsenal and they're so
angry that they want to openly make it
another tool
in their arsenal this is the game the
left play whether it's the media or
whether it's the supreme court whether
it's the executive branch
all institutions become tools in their
arsenal at the same time they claim that
those institutions have institutional
legitimacy
so they play this double game where they
wreck the institutional legitimacy but
then claim that you should respect the
institution
because the institutional legitimacy
ought to remain
and that is untenable it is uns so joe
biden was asked directly yesterday
again again about court packing now
remember kamal harris was asked in
debate just two nights ago
what she would do about court packing
and she refused to answer the question
and mike pence kept drilling her on it
and she kept refusing to answer the
question and then eventually
she just called him a racist so joe
biden standing far away from kamala
harrison an airplane hangar in phoenix
arizona
he was asked specifically about court
packing and his answer is so
unacceptable for any political candidate
that it should have the media up in arms
i imagine i mean you don't have to
imagine it donald trump has many
many many times been asked about
particular kind of crazy policies and
donald trump's go-to
when there is a crazy policy suggestion
that he doesn't know anything about is
to say
well we've been thinking about it we
think about all options elections have
been thought about and the media go oh
well that means that he's totally for it
right i mean we got to take that
seriously we got to take that stuff
super seriously now the difference is
again that is trump's go-to option
but joe biden has thought pretty
seriously about court packing kamala
harris came out in 2019 and talked
openly
about the possibility of court packing
other members of the democratic party
high echelon members of the democratic
party have openly
backed court packing in the democratic
debate many of the candidates said they
would back court packing
joe biden at the time said he would not
now he's going to completely silence on
the issue which
sort of bespeaks that he may have
changed his opinion so he was asked
directly
yesterday this is not the first time he
was asked last week three separate times
in a row whether he would back court
packing he said
people are already voting people are are
already voting and then
so yesterday he was asked about whether
he would back court packing his answer
was mystery meat
there's mr remy what could this chicken
surprise be is it chicken or is it frog
who knows
you're gonna find out afterwards i saw a
tweet yesterday i saw a tweet yesterday
uh characterizing biden's response here
which is
do you take this woman for better or for
worse
do you pledge your chastity and fidelity
you'll find out after the wedding
here was joe biden doing this i mean
it's unbelievable
they'll know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now that is
such an unbelievably unacceptable answer
are you going to completely
de-legitimize the third branch of
government by making it an overtly
political institution
in which you just stack the court with a
bunch of democrats
and he says well you'll find out after
the election you'll find out you know
afterward we have to pass the bill to
find out what's in it
as nancy pelosi once said about
obamacare we found out what was in it
wasn't that great
you have to elect me to find out what
i'm going to do is a crappy
unbelievably crappy response to are you
going to completely wreck
the third branch of government that's
wild that is wild stuff and the media
just sit there and they accept it
i mean they really accept it seriously
there's an article in the washington
post
today talking about how republicans
pounce
very very penalty see here's the rule in
the media as my friend andrew clavin has
said when republicans do something bad
that the bad thing is the story when
democrats do something bad
the republicans pouncing is the story
the washington post
headline was republicans continue
attacking biden harris over hypothetical
court-packing question hypothetical
is that hypothetical when your your own
people have put it out there
when you have said that you refuse to
like hypothetical imagine if somebody
asked donald trump
are you for a federal ban on all
abortions from point of conception
and he said you know we'll have to we'll
have to find out after the election
where i stand on that particular issue
like maybe maybe not i don't know you're
gonna have to find out like you think
the media would be satisfied with that
answer but now
it's republicans pouncing of course so
much pouncing
it's a hypothetical pouncing according
to the washington post democratic
nominee joe biden and running mate
kamala harris are facing growing
pressure to say whether they would pack
the supreme court if the republican-led
senate names amy coney barrett to the
bench
over the past few days the question from
republicans debate moderators and
reporters has dogged the pair
it came up again thursday when biden was
asked at a campaign stop in phoenix if
you would support expanding the supreme
court beyond nine justices
it re-answered the conversation in
earnest after the death of rbg
although the republican control tenant
refused to consider barack obama's
nomination in merrick garland in 2016
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
and his allies have promised to confirm
barrett by november 3rd yes because
the republicans control the executive
and the legislature
or at least the senate in response some
democrats have vowed to leave nothing on
the proverbial table should the party
take control
of the white house and the senate senate
minority leader chuck schumer hinted he
would not rule out
court packing again it is amazing that
the washington post is covering this as
a story of republicans pouncing
if you were talking about the
republicans adding seats to the supreme
court which they could theoretically do
right now they have a majority in the
in the senate presumably the democrats
and
the media would not be talking about
democrats pouncing they'd be talking
about the underlying issue
but joe biden is so confident that the
media will cover his ass for him
that he refuses to answer the most basic
questions knowing that he can literally
get away with anything
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button